seit 20 jahren befindet sich auf dem
mars ich frage mich gefunden hat diese
proben riesiger hüller eindrücklich
biologischer natur der erste
unwiderlegbare beweise für ein leben
außerhalb der erde läuft ist ein film
der auf der interessanten schätzungen
spielt und leute die zum beispiel
sunshine gut fanden von den ball oder
die von christopher nolan der steller
gut fanden oder leute die diese
maschinen gut fand oder gravity gut
fanden die werden diesen film hassen und
alle anderen wenn sie das geringste
bisschen geschmack haben auch denn das
ist ein ganz großer weg
es ist im wesentlichen
familie natürlich gott ohne die kunst
dafür mit sämtlichen schauspieler
überhaupt gibt als ryan ramsay
gyllenhall auch den ein oder anderen
lichtblick gibt da durchaus oder die
romy schneider eine russin das ist die
neue isabella rossellini würde ich sagen
die betroffenen flüssiger rollen die
kühlflüssigkeit winterluft schleife die
leute geben sich die größte mühe den
beratungen am drehort erschienen ist und
zudem locken durch korridore schlitz in
der schwerelosigkeit dann müsste man ja
auch einen eindruck hinterlassen aber
die gelegenheit dafür kriegen sie wie
gesagt nicht von der film ist das
besonders schlimme daran ist dass ein
eigentlich alles was man sowieso schon
sieht und hört permanent auch noch
zusätzlich erklärt wird in einer weise
überhaupt nicht nötig ist wie man hat
zum beispiel mitten in dieser
raumstation ein hologramm dass ein
gelegentlich zeigt wo wer eigentlich ist
weil die sich sozusagen nicht zutrauen
durchschnitte und andere techniken wie
man den normalen filmen hat die handlung
einigermaßen transparent gehalten ist
aber auch gar nicht nötig weil es gibt
überhaupt keine handlung sondern wir
werden halt einen nach dem anderen ab
geburt von dieser schlabber schlingen
schock babbel machte die damals auf die
ausstattung gefallen ist über die
erfahren wir am anfang kurz bafin
wissenschaftler interessiert sich dafür
die besteht nämlich auf stellen die
sowohl muskelzellen die wildesten also
was wieder auge wie auch gehirnzellen
sind also eine sehr leistungsfähige
lebensform sehr interessant und
faszinierend und aus dem grund natürlich
nur dazu da uns umzubringen oder von und
umgebracht zu werden wird die ganze zeit
mit schlimmer musik gesagt dafür schlimm
ist und nicht etwas süßlicher muss liegt
auf die erholung moment da ist leider
manchmal will man sich ärgern oder
andere leute ärgern die kann man dann
auch mitnehmen und ich denke das reicht
aber schon so ziemlich die sinnvollen
gebrauch weil der kinokarte für diesen
führen so ein bisschen ab